バンキラジオ今日から夏休みだお前ら荷
全部終わって
[拍手]
帰れうとはい何遊ぼうさすがに暑すぎるん
よ熱い時は水がってん
だ行くぞおりおりおりおり
[拍手]
え
くそあお母さん特ばお母さんこっちは無料
だよ無料
あ熱中症には気をつけないとね無料の水分
補給だよ
[音楽]
最強お母さん水鉄砲
だやりすぎたか
な
[音楽]
いらっしゃいようわお祭りだはい
いらっしゃいいらっしゃい唐いかがですか
あ祭りくじだ
あと宝くじ2個なんよこれはスイッチが
当たるはずなんよ当たりはあるのこの中に
当たりは絶対あるから
ねおいおい
おい辛いんよ僕は僕は辛い
よ僕は僕はまだ諦めないんよ
僕が1年かけて集めた貯金500円
ぽいぽいあったお
やち
何何何これはここで使うんよはい1回ね
スイッチスイッチスイッチ
スイッチスイッチはもらた
よ終わったよ
2024年は雑草飯確定ない
よおかしいだろこの中に当たりがあるって
言ったじゃんああ当たりはあるよこの中に
それはひどいよ本当に当たりはあるんだね
じゃ調べてもいいよ
[音楽]
ねこの中に当たりはないねそうそうこの中
にはなくて
あたりなんちゃってじゃ犯罪なので
当たり前に警察呼ぶねあタリーズコヒ行き
たくなっちゃったから行こうか
なやった全部持ってくぞあっ
たぜ全部何もねえじゃん
[音楽]
かはいじゃあ汚さず遊ぶのよはい
[拍手]
ねえねみんなこのぷよぷよボールを水に
入れれるとえ
[拍手]
[音楽]
何よこれ汚れてるじゃないやれちゃん掃除
しなさい遊びに行ってき
ますちょっとお母さんが俺を産んだんだろ
責任持って自分で掃除しなきゃだめだろ
確かにじゃないわ待ち
[音楽]
なさいさあ今日はこのプールで遊ぶわよ
すげえ
すげ
わあ
あやけのお母さん出てきてくれて
ありがとうじゃあ宝探しゲームでもし
ましょうかしらみんなプールにある宝箱を
探すのよやった
[音楽]
あれ聞いたあれ聞いたじゃ
ないああれはサメだ
逃げろ私が責任を持ってあんたたちを掃除
してあげるわ
おほほほほこうなっ
たらビッグぷよぷよボールだ
[音楽]
ああ今日で夏休みも終わりなんだから
あんたも切り替えて宿題とかしなさいよ
じゃ片付けておいてねはいあ水やるの忘れ
てたうい棒とアクエリアスを入れ
て栄養の水で大きく育てる
ぞあなんだか眠くなってき
[音楽]
たええ
えななんだこれあ登れるじゃん登って
みようよしよしよしよしよし
[音楽]
うわあ誰
ほほほ私はこの世界の神じゃ神様じゃお
願い聞いてよ夏休みがずっと続いてほしい
んだいいじゃろその願いよ
うわあ夢かあ夏休み終わったから学校行か
なきゃ
やばいやばい遅刻する
あ今日から夏休みだお前ら荷物全部持って
帰れえもしかして本当に夏休みが続くの夢
だけど夢じゃなかっ
[音楽]
たな夏休みだ
あこ行くぞこ行くぞこ行くぞせーの
見つかってんだな
あらららさあゲームを始めようか
あ
うあと宝くじ2個なんよこれはスイッチが
当たるはずなんよこの中に当たりは必ず
入ってるよいや当たりは入ってないよほら
バレたやは俺の親友なんよこの500円で
チョコバナナ怒ってあげるんよチョコ
バナナ2本くださいはい
[音楽]
どうぞのお母さん連れてきてくれて
ありがとうないなは順調に仕込んどいたわ
お母さんも遊ぼうよほらほらほらほらほら
う
[拍手]
べ今日で夏休みも終わりなんだからあんた
も切り替えて宿題とかしなさい終わらない
よ夏休みは
ねへほほ次は3回目の
夏休み今からみだお前ら荷物全部持って
[拍手]
帰れよし3メのループ
だ
[音楽]
また来た
あと宝くじ2なんよこれはスイッチが
当たるはずなんよくじか終わったよなんか
もう言うのもめんどくさいなチョコバナナ
でも食べてよくもう1
回2024年ま短てないん
よやめちゃべん悪いんだけど500円貸し
てくん
ないやのお母さん連れてきてくれて
ありがとういいのよいいのよ
サメだ
逃げろああつまん
な今日で夏休みも終わりなんだからあんた
も切り替えて宿とかしなさい夏休み終わら
ないよまた始まっちゃうよえ神様がループ
てだ証拠にこれ1回目の夏休みの日記
なるほどねもう夏休みなんてゴリゴリだ
分かったわ私がなんとかしてあげるえ
あようやく夏休みも終わったか
なえ夏休み何の
何た
の夏休みも終わり今日からいつもの生活が
始まるお前ら気合いでろ
えやっ
たえやす何この日記嘘ばっかりじゃんプ嘘
じゃないもん本当だもんおいやす宿題はげ
毎回ルプするから忘れてたやってこだ
こらやってこ
やっぱりまだ夏休みが
[拍手]
[音楽]
いいちゃちゃちゃちゃチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしくはチャンネル登録チャンネル
登録チャンネル
登録M